space is the ultimate
frontier and i think what makes a good
astronaut
is perseverance and conviction
[Music]
so we really wanted to sort of channel
our values
and that idea and so i think we identify
with that
frontier-ism
gemini is a crypto exchange and
custodian but really
it's a platform building a bridge to the
future of money
and then into the future of d5 or
decentralized finance and more recently
a bridge into the future of art
are non-fungible tokens they're one of a
kind
what enforces the fact that it's one of
a kind is the cryptography
and the math of the blockchain the same
math
and technology that enforces there will
only be 21 million bitcoin
it's really the advent of cryptocurrency
and that technology
that allowed digital art to have
economics of supply and demand
like offline meet space art as well as
provenance and authenticity
a lot of our experience was like a lot
of other kids growing up collecting
baseball cards
comic books so the collectivity of
creative things
was there and that really informed our
journey
with with nifty gateway and nfts
we're very early in our learning process
of the fine art world so i think we're
we're news but i think that's also
because we're beginners
that's an advantage of how we we aren't
encumbered by
the assumptions of the legacy art world
so when we're looking at things like
nifty gay we say why not
we let our curiosity drive us
and sort of lead us so we follow our
curiosity
we follow our passion one of gemini's
values
is beginner's mind we always want to be
beginners
and not bring our previous assumptions
we were not financial experts when we
came to bitcoin
and that was an asset because we saw the
possibilities
in the same thing when we saw ethereum
and other cryptocurrencies
in nfps the beginner's mind has served
us uh
very well and allows us the freedom to
imagine what could be
not always looking in the past
tyler spent a lot of time dming artists
and trying to get them
excited about the platform and i think a
lot of those conversations
you know didn't really go anywhere
because a lot of people didn't see that
vision
and now basically the entire art world
the entire entertainment world
is knocking down our doors so it's
really interesting to see
us being proactive in that cold call
outreach
and now it's completely inbound
every time you get a no you're one step
closer to a yes so don't take it too
hard